The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocu.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
First of all, I was in
touch by email with George,
and he asked me to flash
this up again, which
was from a couple
of lectures ago,
because he thought this was
very critical and very important
that you sort of
understood what it says.
So I'm going to just say
a few things about it.
I guess the first
thing to note is
that it compares these
two different cases,
coherent imaging and
incoherent imaging.
And you see that, apart from
that, these two, the top half
and the bottom half,
are really identical.
So you use the same
method in either case,
except that, of course, in
the coherent case you're
working with amplitudes,
whereas in the incoherent case
you're working with intensities.
But apart from that,
it's identical.
So what it's saying is, if you
illuminate a thin transparency,
then you get a field on the far
side of this transparency which
goes into your optical system.
So this is his GN.
And to calculate the
image, you can either
do it by convolving that
with a point spread function
to get the amplitude out, or you
can do it in the Fourier domain
by Fourier transforming
to get the object spectra,
and then multiplying it
by a transfer function
and then getting the field out.
And then once you've got
the field, of course,
you can calculate the
intensity from that
just by doing the
modulus square.
So the difference
between these two things
is here we working
with aptitudes,
so we have a coherent
point spread function
and an amplitude
transfer function,
whereas for this one,
the incoherent case,
we have an intensity point
spread function, which is just
the modulus square of this.
And here we have an optical
transfer function, which
is the autocorrelation of this.
So that's really
all there is to do,
all there is that you need to
know about calculating images.
Any questions about that?
So I'll just-- as
I say, I'll just
flash that because George
said he wanted me to.
And now we'll go on to
where we got up to last time
in the lecture.
So George suggested-- he sent
me some more material for today,
and he also asked me to add some
extra to it of my own material.
But I don't know how
far we get with this.
So we've still got some left
over from last time, actually,
and then the bit
that George sent.
You might be fed up by then.
But anyway, if we've
still got some time
and you're not fed up, I'll
carry on with some stuff
that I put in there which
is to do with focusing.
But it might be--
you might think
it's sort of rather higher level
than the rest of the course.
So this is not for--
this bit that I've added is
not for examining or anything.
It's meant just
for your interest.
Anyway, this is where we
got up to, the defocus ATF.
So this, again, you remember--
let's make it bigger.
Now, what's going on?
I've gone the wrong thing.
I should [INAUDIBLE].
Sorry.
I haven't got my glasses on.
I can't see what I'm doing.
And it's all in
a different place
from across the
version of PDF that--
PowerPoint that I use.
Anyway, here we are,
the defocus ATF.
So you remember, we
introduced this last time.
We said that if you've
got a defocused object,
then you can work
out the imaging of it
by using an amplitude transfer
function just like before,
but it's not just
the normal one.
It's modified by the
effects of defocus.
What happens is that you
have to multiply the transfer
function by complex exponential,
e to the i, this thing.
It therefore becomes complex.
And you can divide that up
into two parts, a real part
and an imaginary part.
The real part will image
the real information
of the objects,
which is basically
the absorption of the object.
And that's what this shows here,
the real part of that transfer
function, which is
cosine of this thing.
And so this is the cutoff
of the optical system here.
Sorry.
No, it isn't, is it?
No, sorry.
The cutoff, I guess,
is some arbitrary place
I guess it's not
actually shown here.
But anyway, the
fact is that as you
change the amount
of defocus, this
will be scaled accordingly
relative to the cutoff
of the transfer function.
So you can imagine if
the transfer function was
right in here, it would
be almost as though it was
the same as an in-focus system.
And then as you make the
cutoff wider and wider
relative to this cos
curve, you see you getting
more and more of these wiggles.
So this was a case where
it's not changing very much.
So there we are.
There's the region
where it's non-zero,
and so it's not changing
very much in that region.
And so we said that
corresponds to multifocus.
And then the next
case we looked at
was now when it's
got a lot of defocus.
So you can see here, it
starts really wiggling.
Remember-- I said
this last time--
this is actually cos
of this thing squared.
So that's why it doesn't look
like an ordinary cos function,
because of the x squared.
So it scales it in
this nonlinear way.
And so here's the and it
cut off again in this case.
Now, in this case
you've got some wiggles,
and those wiggles are going to
lead to artifacts in the image.
Firstly, because of the
fact this goes negative,
you can see there's some
spatial frequencies will
be imaged with the wrong sign.
So it's just like if
you've got a Fourier
series for, let's say, a square
wave, if you take the Fourier
series for a square wave and
you change the sign of some
of those components, it
doesn't look like a square wave
anymore.
So you get a very poor
image in that case.
So this is really bad
news for the image.
And the other thing that
George mentions up there
is that, of course,
there's regions
where the value of the transfer
function is very small.
So this spatial frequency
here, for example, is not
going to be imaged at all.
So you'll get some
gaps in the response
of the different transfer
of spatial frequencies.
So the significance of
depth of focus in imaging--
so here he shows a 4F system.
It shows here the NA
in and the NA out.
And you remember, of course,
that as you changed the NA,
you also change
the magnification.
You change the
lateral magnification,
and you also change the
longitudinal or axial
magnification.
That goes as the NA squared.
And so we define
these two terms.
Depth of field is basically
that the defocus tolerance
in the object space, so far
you can move the objects
without it going too
much out of focus.
And so this gives some idea
about the value of that, then.
The depth that
depth of a field is
given by this lambda
over 2NA squared.
You get this NA squared because
the longitudinal magnification
also goes as NA squared.
And then on the other
side, in the image side,
you have a depth of focus
rather than a depth of field.
Notice in the title, he calls
it DoF, which can mean either,
so Depth of Field,
Depth of Focus.
You'll find that, of course,
in general terminology people
often use these phrases
almost interchangeably
and are not very careful
about using the right one
for the right space.
But this is what
it really means.
Depth of field is how much
you can move the object.
Depth of focus is how much
you can move the screen here
without it going out of focus.
And you can see that this is
expressing the depth of focus
now in terms of
numerical aperture.
You get the same
expression, but it's now
this NA rather than that one.
But of course, the
magnification also
goes as NA squared as well.
So the image of the bit that's
in focus, here, of the object
is, of course, the same as the
depth of focus of the system.
Is that all clear?
Yeah?
Good.
OK.
Even though our derivations
were carried out
for spatially coherent imaging,
exactly the same arguments
you can use for the
incoherent case.
So the idea of a--
we showed the defocused
amplitude transfer function,
in the same way you can
also have a defocused OTF.
So let's think of
now what happens
if we've got some objects which
has got some height variations.
Here he's taking the
case of a surface,
and he's called this
a 2 and 1/2 D object.
I think he's probably called
it that because I sometimes
use that terminology.
I'm not the only one, really.
I didn't invent it.
But people often
use this 2 and 1/2 D
to represent something
which is not a 2D object.
It's not flat, it's
got some depth.
But it's not a true
3D object in that
it's got no internal structure.
It's just a surface.
So anyway, in this
case, this is the object
and this is its image.
And you can see that if
this object is quite deep,
it's going to be deeper
than that depth of field
of the system.
And so some parts of that
are going to be out of focus.
And so this is a
region, for example,
which is a long way away
from the focal plane,
and therefore it's going
to be imaged out of focus.
And here it corresponds
to this region here.
Notice, if you look at this
image, it's inverted in x.
But you see that
in the z direction,
a distance which is
moved this way here
is also moved this way here.
So there's no inversion
in the z direction.
Did I hear a question over
there or was it just someone
shuffling around?
No.
OK.
So as George points out
here, what this means then
for this particular object
is the point spread function
is not now spatially invariant.
It's a spatially
shift variance PSF
because different
parts of this surface
are going to experience
a different point spread
function because they might
be in or out of focus.
So yeah, and the part, just
like before, the part which
is in focus is given by this
depth of field, which we just
had before.
So you can either think
of it as a depth of field
or a depth of focus,
the same expression.
So this is an example of this.
Let's take an object
which is a letter
M. I guess he didn't use MIT
this time because he wants
to use the same for each so that
you can see how each of them
is affected by the different
point spread function.
So this is in the focal
plane, and then this
is to depth of fields
out of the focal plane.
This is for depth the fields
So when you image
that you can see
that it's going to become--
this one's going to be in focus.
It's still a bit
blurred, of course,
because of the refraction
effect in the imaging.
So this is convolved with
the point spread function
of the coherent optical system.
And then this is for the
two defocused ones, getting
more and more out of focus.
So right now, once
we've got that blur,
what can we do about it?
And there's been
quite a lot of papers
that have looked at this
question of whether you
can actually undo the blur.
Deblurring, they
call it, or sometimes
deconvolution because if
you think of the blurring
as being a
convolution, you wanted
to undo that, you want
to do a deconvolution.
So what we actually get
then, in the Fourier domain
the spectrum of the image
is equal to the spectrum
of the object multiplied
by some transfer function.
And this would be
true whether it's
coherent or
incoherent, in general.
They'd be the same
sort of effects,
but you'd have to
work with intensities
rather than amplitudes.
And so what we say
then is that if we--
this is the blurred
thing, so we can actually
blur it by just dividing
by that to get rid of it.
So if we get our
image, we multiply by 1
over the transfer
function, and that gives us
our deblurred
version of the image.
So as he calls it here, you
can call it inverse filtering,
or sometimes called
deconvolution.
But that is actually--
probably you all thought
of, that can't work.
It doesn't sound as
like it ought to work.
And of course, it
doesn't work very well.
We're going to show a bit
more about this in a minute.
In particular, it
really goes wrong
if this thing goes
to 0, obviously.
So you can't know
very much about that.
And then also, if
it goes to something
which is even very small, you
have to amplify it by a lot.
And when you amplify it, you're
going to amplify the noise.
So you'll end up with
a noisy reconstruction
after you've done that.
So this sort of
inverse filtering
invariably increases
the noise in the image.
And so how can we
get around that?
Well, we just get around
the 0 by making it so
that there isn't a 0 anymore.
So this is our new version.
You can see that if mu
were 0, this would just
become the same as before.
This is H times H star, so
the H stars would cancel,
and this is 1 over H.
So if this is being
compared with that,
then it becomes
the same as before.
But if this becomes small,
then we're just left with this,
and it avoids it blowing
up and giving infinity.
So if mu is 0, it reduces
to the direct filter,
and we just described that
that's not a good thing to do.
So the more noise
there is there,
the bigger you need to
make this to avoid getting
too much noise in the image.
So as the noise
increases, you would tend
to increase the value of mu.
Yeah, so here it's saying
that if the signal and noise
both obey particular
type of statistics,
then you can find what the
optimum value of mu is.
And we find then
that it's equal to 1
over the signal-to-noise
ratio, and this
is what's called a vena filter.
So this N comes down to
be the same as a vena
filter, which you might have
come across, some of you,
in other things.
So what we are doing,
really, is you're
amplifying the spatial
frequencies that
have been pushed down
by the imaging process.
But if there is if they
become smaller than the noise,
then you don't do that anymore.
So he's going to give
an example of this.
So this is the convolution
using this second
of regularized inverse filter.
And yeah, OK, he's
saying here that he's
assuming he knows that
depth before he does this.
So obviously, that is something
you wouldn't always necessarily
know.
But he knows the
depth, therefore
he can calculate what
the transfer function was
on the imaging side.
And therefore he knows
what filter inverse
filter to apply in order to
get the best reconstruction.
And you can see that it works
extremely well for this one.
This one is slightly blurred,
slightly a bit more blurred.
And you can see also that
the background here--
or at least, I can
see on this screen,
but this one doesn't
show very much--
the background is becoming
not black anymore.
And then this is what
happens if you've
got a noisy image, if you
add noise to the original--
to the image before you
do the deconvolution.
Now you see that
that actually it's
not working nearly so well.
And this one here,
you can't really
make out what there is there.
So this is showing that
these methods can work,
but you can see
that there are also
limits to how well
they can work,
and especially in the
presence of noise.
Actually, I should
mention that, of course,
at MIT in the Media
Lab, there's a lot
of work going on in
this area of what
they call computational
photography, which is all
to do with changing the
properties of the camera
in order to make it so that
this sort of reconstruction
is more efficient.
So it turns out that if
you're clever about the design
of the imaging system,
you can actually
make it so that this
all works a lot better.
But we weren't going
to go into all that.
Oh, sorry.
I've got this wrong.
This one was the--
sorry, this was the--
oh, yeah, that's right.
This is the image before you've
done the inverse filtering,
and this is the
image after you've
done the inverse filtering.
So it's actually
doing quite well.
This one here is pretty well
not very different from that.
And this one, as before, is not
as good, but doing pretty well.
Of course if, you didn't know
what the height of these things
is, then you might have to
use some iterative algorithm
in order to come up with
the best reconstruction.
You can imagine also that--
so this is for this
so-called 2 and 1/2 D object.
You could imagine an object
which really did have structure
inside itself, so
maybe these three Ms
would be on top of each
other and semi-transparent.
And then the trick would
be to try to actually
produce a reconstruction of the
3D object from the 3D image,
and there are actually
computer packages
that you can get to do just
that very sort of thing.
So that was what we
should have done,
and we'll now go on
to today's lecture.
And so today's lecture
is, first of all,
about polarization, which we've
been talking about in the lab
today--
or yesterday, wasn't it?
So that's a bit topical.
And then George wrote these.
So the bit that I've
added extra is basically
addressing these points
here, effects of polarization
on imaging in a microscope
objective or a lens
with a high numerical aperture.
So we'll start off
with the polarization.
I'm not sure what he said about
polarization, first of all.
But basically, then,
the wave equation
for an electromagnetic field
is basically a vector wave
equation.
It's a function of
electric field here.
And we had then that
the polarization
is some function of
the electric field
and how the relationship
between these
depends on the sort of material.
And so this is giving
some different examples.
The simple case is this one,
which we did look at earlier,
is where the polarization
is proportional
to the electric field.
And you remember that you get
D by adding the P to the E.
And so here, this is called
the electric susceptibility,
and P equals Chi times E.
So if this is a constant,
this is just a linear
relationship, which
is how we described it before.
But there are two ways that
that can break down in practice.
And usually, actually, for
materials where it breaks down,
it breaks down for both at
the same time, unfortunately.
So it becomes very complicated.
But here we've written it with
these two effects separately.
this.
Is where actually the
relationship is still linear,
but P is related to e
not by a simple scalar
relationship like this, but
by a tensor relationship.
So the direction of P is
not in the same direction
as the direction
of E. And so you've
got this 3 by 3
matrix, which describes
the properties of the material.
And this will depend on--
well, for a isotopic material,
like a crystal or something
like that, it would depend
on the crystal structure.
Of course, if you've got some
complicated varying objects,
then it can be all sorts of
even more complicated things.
So that's the first case.
So this is what's going to
lead to some interesting
polarization effects as
you put that electric field
into a crystal, for example.
And then this is
the other one which
is now looking at isotopic
material, but nonlinear.
So this is now no
longer a constant.
And so what that
means, you can you
could expand it
as a power series.
And you can see that there
might be some extra terms here.
This is what's called
the Kerr effect.
There's effectively
a susceptibility
which is dependent on the
intensity of the light which
shines on it.
And of course, you
might expect that there
will be higher orders of
this as well, of course.
These sorts of
effects, you're only
going to excite these if you
have a large value of E. It's
a bit like, if you imagine
how this all comes about,
this comes about
because your material
is made up of atoms which
are all bonded together
and joined to each
other with springs.
And when you apply
the electric field,
it makes these atoms
vibrate against the spring.
And if the vibrations
are small, then it's
all going to
satisfy Hooke's law,
and it's going to be linear.
But if you increase
the forcing term,
then the vibrations get bigger,
Hooke's law breaks down,
and the vibrations
become nonlinear.
That's the basic physics
of what's going on here.
So this is what's
called the Kerr effect.
There is actually
another effect which
George hasn't mentioned here.
There's another-- you see
this is actually E cubed here.
But you can have an
effect where this
is E squared, which is called
the-- what's it called?
The Pockels effect.
I was really only asking
because I'd forgotten
the word for a minute.
But my students here know that
I'm always forgetting names,
and they usually
come back eventually.
Did you see what that did?
Oh, yeah, it did
this, the relationship
between the susceptibility
and the refractive index.
And this is saying
that the phase delay
depends on the polarization.
And in this one, the
index of refraction
depends on the intensity.
So this is nonlinear optics.
And as I say, those last
two effects very often
come together.
So this is now talking
about polarization of light.
I think that probably
George must have mentioned
this to some degree earlier on.
But what this is showing,
then, is a plane wave of light.
It's part linearly polarized
in the x direction--
sorry, the y direction.
This is taken as y.
So the electric field
is in the y direction,
which actually means that
the magnetic field is going
to be in the x direction
because they're
at right angles with each
other, if you remember.
And you remember that you can
think of the wave propagating
in two different ways.
One is to think of it other
at a certain instant of time,
so what we call here
it's a snapshot,
and then we plot what
happens as a function of z.
So of course, we have
to do this because it's
difficult to plot it against
space and time at the same time
because it's difficult to
visualize what's going on.
So you can see here this
electric field is always
in the same plane, and
it's a maximum here.
It reduces, it becomes 0.
It then increases in
the negative direction,
comes back to 0 again,
and so on and so on.
So this is linearly polarized
light as a function of space.
And then this one shows the same
thing as a function of time.
So we're looking at now one
particular value of positions
that equals 0, and we're
looking at how this
varies as a function of time.
Exactly the same
diagram, of course.
You probably saw when I
flicked to the next slide,
it didn't change at all.
It just changed the caption.
And this is what circular
polarization does.
Circular polarization, you can
see what this is trying to--
it looks a bit complicated here.
But what it's really doing is
actually quite straightforward.
It's actually rotating.
This electric vector is
rotating either with distance
or with time, according to
which way you do the plot.
And the length of this
line stays the same.
So this is what we mean
by circular polarization.
And this is showing
how, actually, you
can think of
circular polarization
as being made up
of two components--
one linearly
polarized in this side
in the y direction, one linearly
polarized in the x direction.
And so you can see that
there are also out of phase
by 90 degrees.
So you can see now that in
this distance, position,
this is plotted against z again.
Here this one is a
maximum, this one is 0.
So the electric field
is in the x direction.
And then as you go,
as you travel along,
this gets smaller,
but this gets bigger.
So this position here,
the electric field
is now polarized
in the y direction.
And then this one goes
back down to 0 again,
and this one gets bigger.
So this is exactly
equivalent to the case
that I showed before, the
circular polarized case.
I might add that
electrical polarization
is where the amplitude of this
component and this component
are not equal.
So if that was the
case, it would-- again,
you that you'd think
of this electric field
vector as rotating, but
the length of the vector
would also change as it rotates.
And of course, you
can have two cases.
You can have it
rotating clockwise,
or you can have it
rotating anti-clockwise.
So these are called
left- and right-hand
circular polarization.
So this is showing
an end-on view.
So this is x and y.
So this thing is pointing
out towards you, isn't it,
that means.
No, it means it's
going away, isn't it?
But is it right?
Because it's left-handed
coordinate system.
If that's the case because x--
oh, no, it's not.
No, it's right.
It's right.
It's the right-handed
coordinate system.
Yeah, x cross y
goes away from you.
And so this is
showing, then, end-on,
what happens to this
electric vector.
And the wonders
of modern science
have in fact changed the
circular polarization
to electrical polarization
without me doing anything.
Now, so next is to
introduce some--
sorry.
I missed that one.
There were lots of these things
that my computer misinterpreted
from George's computer.
And I changed most of them,
but I missed one there.
That should say left
lambda over 4 plate.
I don't know what the difference
is what he put in there.
Do you know what he's put in
there to make it go like that?
Anyway, he did this on his Mac.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, but it's a
funny font as well.
Anyway, so this is
showing what would happen
if you put some birefringent--
a special birefringent
material here,
which is what's called
a lambda by 4 plate.
And what this does is it
changes the relative phase
of the components of electric
field in two directions
by a different amount as it
transmits through the crystal.
And so if you arrange
the orientation of it
correctly relative
to the light, it
has this effect of changing
the linear polarization
into circular polarization.
The way it really does
that is that this--
you would say that
this you can think
of as being made up of two
linearly polarized components,
and this you can always
think of as being made up
of two linearly
polarized components
as well at 45 degrees to that.
So you just resolve that
into two components.
So the circular
polarized, you get that
very simply by just changing
the relative phase of those two
linear polarized components.
That's how it works, but I
think here he's just trying
to show you what it does.
And then the other
important device
that people use is a
is a lambda by 2 plate
rather than a lambda
by 4 plate, and that
has the property of changing x
polarized, linearly polarized
light into y polarized light.
And again, you can see
how this is working
by thinking in terms of
resolving this in so two
components at 45 degrees
to it, and then changing
the relative sign.
Maybe I should do that.
This doesn't [INAUDIBLE].
Is it switched on?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So maybe I
can just do that quickly.
So what I'm saying is that
this, you can think of it--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This
one you can think
of as being resolved into
these two components.
And then the crystal
is then changing
the relative phase of
one of these relative
to that, making that.
And so now the
polarization is like this.
So that's how it's working.
For the lambda by 4 plate,
what it was doing was
it was changing the relative
phase of this and this
by 90 degrees, not by 180
degrees, which would give you
a circularly polarized light.
But in order to get
this effect, you
have to get the right
orientation of the polarization
relative to the crystal axes.
So that part he hasn't actually
said anything about here.
The other thing-- maybe you'd
be interested to know this.
Of course, if you put linearly
polarized light in and get
circularly polarized
light out, what
would happen if you
went the other way?
Well, in fact, it does
work the other way.
You can put it in
circularly polarized light
and get out linearly
polarized light.
So you can do either
of those two things.
The other thing that
you might worry about
is it's interesting that if we
change the phase of this light,
then it's going to change the
phase of that light, isn't it?
And yeah, maybe that's
not leading anywhere.
I won't say any more about.
OK, think about this.
Yeah.
Oh, well, there we are.
I've already-- I've
jumped the gun a bit.
So he's saying, what
happens here then?
So we've got incoming linearly
polarized light, the lambda
by 4 plate.
What does the lambda
by 4 plate do?
Circular polarized.
So we've got circular
polarized light on here.
It strikes a mirror
and it reflects.
What do we get after
it's reflected?
That's a bit hard now, isn't it?
Opposite circular, right.
And then this gets back
to here and it goes back
through this birefringent plate.
So what does it do?
AUDIENCE: Same.
PROFESSOR: Same polarization.
Is that right?
It rotates by 180 degrees.
This is slower, actually.
It's gone through a lambda
by 2 plate then, isn't it?
Well, I mean--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, sorry.
Yeah, you're quite right.
Yeah.
OK everyone, about that?
I guess the next
thing is to say what
would happen if you change that
mirror by a phase conjugate
mirror.
But maybe that's too difficult
for us to think about.
And then remember that--
I think we had this
before as well--
that when you have
lights interfering,
the electric field, it's
only the parallel components
of electric field
that interfere.
So if you've got two waves
where the electric fields are
at right angles to each other,
then they don't interfere.
So this is showing
this case here.
We've got two plane
polarized waves.
They're polarized at right
angles to each other,
and so they won't interfere.
And therefore, if you
look at the trying
to get an interference
pattern, you
won't see anything in this case.
And this is showing
them in the same plane.
And then they would interfere
, and you would get some
interference pattern with
maxima a minima like this.
Another interesting one I
guess I might draw over here
is what happens if you--
this is our screen.
And let's say we've got
two waves coming in.
One, let's say, is
polarized like this,
and the other one
is coming in here
and it's polarized like this.
You see?
So we've got these
two waves coming in.
And you can see that their
electric field vectors are
at right angles to
each other, and so this
is another example where
they're not going to interfere.
So you wouldn't see any
interference fringes
in this case.
So this corresponds to
what's called p-polarization.
So if we did this the
opposite, if we did it
with the electric field in this
direction, and the other one's
coming in also with the actually
field in this direction,
then you can see these are
now in parallel directions.
and so you would see fringes
where these two plane
waves interfere.
So I've drawn this for
the particular case.
This is supposed
to be 90 degrees.
Right, OK.
That's all George's material.
That was the end of George.
It didn't end with a
particularly startling thing.
So that's really the end of
the course as George wrote it.
But he did ask me, as I
say, to do a bit more.
So what I think I'll do,
why don't we have a break
now for five minutes?
And then I'll start again
in five minutes' time.
So this is-- now it's
going to be talking
about focusing of light.
And as I said before, this
material I'm going to do now
is just for interest.
It's not going to be examinable.
And if you're not
interested, you
can go and have a cup
of coffee instead.
I don't really mind.
But some people might be
interested in learning
a bit more about
focusing of light.
So I was going to say a bit
more about focusing of light,
and in particular some of the
funny things that happen when
you look at focusing of light
with a microscope objective,
so the tight focusing of light.
And this is actually a
picture of the intensity
in the focal region of a lens,
not high numerical aperture
in this case.
This is according
to paraxial optics.
This is a picture taken
from [INAUDIBLE] Wolf.
And it's similar but
not identical to the one
that George showed on the last
lecture or the lecture before.
So this is the focal plane.
This is the optic axis.
And of course, what
you're really seeing,
this is actually going
to be radially symmetric.
So if you imagine this was
being revolved around the axis,
you'd have the shape of
this complete surface.
And you can see what
happens is so this
is the focal plane where
you got the Airy disk.
And then as you go
out of focus, then you
start getting this
strange sort of almost
like a sort of butterfly shape.
So this calculation that's
given in [INAUDIBLE] Wolf,
it first of all,
as I've said, it's
using this small
angle approximation.
You assume that sine theta
is the same as theta.
And it also makes an assumption,
which is called the Debye
approximation.
So I'll say a bit more about
the Debye approximation.
But before I carry on,
I'll say another thing.
I'd forgotten I'd put this in.
And that is that there was a
really neat paper published
way back in 1964 by
McCutcheon, where
he showed that you can postulate
the idea, the concept of what
he calls the 3D pupil.
And this is the cap
of a sphere where
it's cut off at this angle
alpha, the angle of the lens.
And if you do love the 3D
Fourier transform of this--
ta-da-- you get back to that.
So isn't that neat?
So I guess, if you think a bit
more about it, it's probably--
I think you can satisfy yourself
that perhaps it's right.
This is in k space,
effectively, then.
And what it's really saying
is that because the light
satisfies the wave equation,
the modulus of k is constant,
and therefore the locus of
this is a sphere of radius k,
so very simple.
So light propagating-- this
convergent light propagating
will have a k vector which lies
on the surface of this sphere.
So I just added that just
because I thought people
might find it a bit intriguing.
You can sort of generalize
a lot of imaging theory
into 3D using this
same sort of approach.
But I'm not going to say
anything more about that now.
What I'm going to do
now is talk about--
so this is this Debye
approximation again.
You remember, we said there's
two ways of calculating
to two different
optical systems, which
give virtually the same or
similar sort of results.
This one I'll look
at first of all.
This is where you
got the aperture stop
in the front focal
plane of the lens.
This is a distance f.
And then in this plane here,
you will get the Airy disk.
So the pattern I described
a couple of slides
ago for the field is in 3D space
would be in this region here.
So in this plane here, you
get Fraunhofer diffraction,
and then in the regions around
it you get Fresnel diffraction.
But you can get quite similar
results, if you remember,
by using this sort of system.
So this is where
the aperture stop
is not actually in the front
focal plane of the lens, but it
actually in the
plane of the lens.
Or you could think another way
of doing this experiment would
be to get a convergent beam
and place a circular aperture
in that convergent beam.
So the question is, what do
you get in the focal region
in that case?
And it turns out that if
you satisfy this condition,
that a squared over lambda
z is very large, where
is a is this radius here--
this is called the
Fresnel number.
And if that quantity
is very large,
it means that what you'll
get in this focal region
is very similar to this.
Actually, there's a
parabolic phase term
that we described when
we did the Fourier
optics that makes it different.
But the intensity is going to be
the same as for this case here.
So these are two
cases where you can
get this Debye approximation.
So in this case, it's exact
for this particular geometry.
In this case, it's
an approximation
which is obeyed if this
Fresnel number is very large.
And then, not that
long ago, people
realized that this
was an approximation,
an assumption that was made.
And there was a very nice
paper published by Li and Wolf,
so this paper here--
1984, quite a long time ago now,
but not that long, but anyway,
as history goes, Li and Wolf.
And they showed
what would happen
if this Fresnel
number was not large
but was of some
intermediate value.
In this case, N equals 10.
So you see what happens is that
this pattern has got distorted.
You can see that it's
tending to sort of fan out.
And the physical
explanation of that
is that, effectively,
the light is
being distracted by the
aperture and spreading
because of diffraction effects.
And that is superimposed
on the focusing effect.
So the lens is trying
to focus the light down,
and the diffraction is tending
to focus the light out.
And so you get a sort of balance
between these two things.
So in this focal plane here,
you get the same intensity
as you would if the Debye
approximation was valid.
But in the region elsewhere,
it's a bit different.
It's scaled according to some
sort of affine transformation,
I think it probably would be.
What do you think?
What do you think, [INAUDIBLE]?
But one very interesting
thing that happens
is that it turns
out-- you can't really
see it very well
from this diagram,
but the maximum intensity is no
longer in the focal plane, no
longer in the
geometrical focal plane.
It's shifted towards
the aperture.
And that is called the
focus shift effect,
and there's been a
lot of papers that
have been concerned with that
and calculating what happens
for lots of different cases.
So that's the Debye
approximation.
That shows what happens
if it isn't true.
But now I'm going to go back.
And all the rest I'm
going to carry on now
is talking about what happens
if the paraxial approximation
breaks down, but the Debye
approximation is valid.
The case when the Debye
approximation is not valid
and it's a high numerical
aperture is very complicated,
and there have been
very few papers
that I've treated that case.
Anyway, tight focusing of light.
We get light, we put it
into a microscope objective.
The light then-- a
microscope objective,
a dry microscope objective
might have a numerical aperture
of 0.95, which means that the
light is converging something
maybe over 70 degrees relative
to the axis, so very--
you can't really think of 70
degrees as being a small angle,
I guess.
So the normal paraxial
approximations break down.
And this is some sort of areas
where we might want to do this.
The one, of course, that I'm
most interested in, microscopy,
but also laser micromachining,
optical data storage,
optical lithography, laser
trapping and cooling, looking
at the physics of
light-atom interactions,
and cavity quantum
electrodynamics.
So there's a lot
of basic physics
that's being done nowadays that
uses these sort of principles,
too.
So this is how we
model the light.
Again, we've got--
just like before,
we think of the
aperture as being
placed in the front
focal plane of the lens.
Of course, the lens
is very complicated.
It's got loads of
pieces of glass in.
But we think of it just
as like a black box,
and we describe it just
by this surface here,
which is called the
equivalent refractive locus.
And what that is, is
the locus of points
where this ray and
this ray intersect.
And actually, if you've got
a well-designed system that
is satisfies what's
called the sine condition,
this surface will be a sphere.
But I'm not going to go
into the details of that.
I'm just going to assume it's
a sphere in what comes next.
So in this case,
you've effectively
got lots of plane waves
incident in the focus.
But unlike the paraxial
case, we really
have to take into account
now the polarization
of these electric fields and
add together the electric fields
in the focal region.
And so this is what
happens after the light's
gone through the lens.
It starts off as
being plane polarized.
So in my diagram here the red
represents the electric field,
say.
So we start off with
the electric field
being plane polarized in
the vertical direction.
And then after it's
gone through the lens,
the rays are focused on
the focal point, which is
at the center of this sphere.
But if you actually
calculate what
happens to the electric field
vector, this is what it does.
After you've focused
it, the electric field
lies on the surface of the
sphere with this geometry
that-- you see that
these lines all
go through a point on the
far side of the sphere.
And the same is true for
the magnetic field as well.
If you calculate what happens,
this is what you find happens.
And you can show that this is
actually exactly the same field
as you would get if you
placed at the center
an electric dipole
along this axis
and a magnetic dipole
along the y-axis.
So if you add together those
fields, you would get this.
And one more thing
to say is, you
can see that if you've got a
small aperture system, low NA,
you're in this region here.
And you can see now it's
becoming very close to being
linearly polarized again.
It's only when you
get to big angles
that it starts becoming
a bit more complicated.
So Richards and Wolf in 1959--
so this is the same Emil
Wolf who wrote the book.
And in their paper--
I haven't got the
reference here, I'm sorry.
But anyone remember what
it was published in?
I've forgotten.
No, it doesn't matter.
Proceedings of the Physical
Society, I think, maybe.
But anyway, it doesn't matter.
You can easily find it on
the web if you're after it.
They showed-- you found it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, Proceedings
of the Royal Society
of London in 1959.
They showed that the
field in the focal region
could be written in this form.
So rather than just have
one diffraction integral,
we now end up with
three for the three--
defining these three integrals.
And then these are
the electric fields
in the focal region, written
in terms of these integrals--
i0, i1, and i2.
And these things are very
similar to the paraxial things.
The normal paraxial one is a bit
similar to this, with the j0.
And this is an extra
bit which comes about
because of the system
satisfying the sine condition.
And I'll draw it for
you, what's happening.
Basically, if this is this
aplanatic sphere surface,
if you put in light,
plane polarized light,
into this system,
you can see, if this
is uniform intensity
when it goes in,
you can see that the amount of
energy that's gone into here
and the amount of energy that's
going to go into this angle,
which is very much bigger,
is going to be the same.
So you see what I'm saying?
So this amount of
energy is going
to be squeezed into this angle,
whereas this amount of energy
is going to be spread
out over this angle.
So this produces
this factor here.
And then you can
calculate what happens.
So this is-- yeah,
I'm sorry about that.
You see, you write things
like that not so ti
can be symmetric.
But of course, what I
mean is that this is not
circularly symmetric.
This really should be a circle
before the modern technology
distorted it.
And so rather than the normal
Airy disk, what you get
is this elliptical
focal spot like this.
And this is another calculation.
These are both from a
couple of my papers.
This one is a really old
paper, 1977, really old.
And this one was from a
bit more recent, 1997.
So this was written
with Peter Torok.
And we came up here with a
new way of calculating it
where, basically, we look
at the multimodal expansion
of the field over the
sphere and express it
as a sum of these
spherical harmonics,
the modes of the sphere.
And so this becomes a very
actually quite computationally
efficient way of
calculating things.
And this is for
two systems, then.
This is for an angle of
pi by 3, so 60 degrees,
and this is for 90 degrees.
So this is if you're actually
the limiting case, when
you're actually focusing a
whole hemisphere of light
onto the focus.
And you can see that the
sort of general shape
stays much the same,
but it changes a bit
as you change the aperture.
The other thing I was
going to say a bit about
is Bessel beams.
I don't think George did
anything about Bessel beams
in the end, but I did
see it as a title on some
on the contents of
some of the lectures,
as though it was
just about to come.
But maybe I just missed it.
But anyway, this
is a concept that
is quite interesting
at the moment.
Basically, there are three ways
I'm showing here of doing it.
One is what happens
if you put in your--
this is the aperture
stop of this lens,
and we've put this central
obstruction so that it becomes
just that annular region.
And we make the width of this
annulus very, very narrow.
Then, you remember, just
in the last lecture,
we looked at what happens
for this annular lens.
And we know that
what happens is,
compared with the Airy disk,
the central lobe gets narrower,
but the side lobes get bigger.
Well, it turns out that
in the limiting cases,
this becomes very narrow, you
get the Airy disk becomes,
given by this very simple
expression, just j0 squared,
where j0 is a Bessel function.
So that's why it's
called a Bessel beam.
And it has this
very nice property
that actually this is it this
satisfies the wave equation.
So it's like a sort
of mode of free space.
So this Bessel beam propagates
with an infinite depth
of focus.
It just propagates
without spreading,
and so that's why
these beams have become
of quite a lot of interest.
Actually, the concept
is really quite old.
There was a device
proposed by MacLeod in 1954
for producing something
rather similar,
which is called the Axicon.
An Axicon is like a
conical piece of glass.
It's like a conical prism.
And you can see, then,
that a prism refracts
the light parallel, like this.
And so you can see wherever
you are along this axis
you can see that
what you see is light
that's coming at the
same angle, and so you
can see from this how you get
this increased depth of focus
of this system.
And another system was proposed,
again, a long time ago,
by Dyson, to do this
not with a prism
but with a diffractive
optical structure.
So you make a sort
of grating, which
is a bit like a zone plate
except the zone plate--
the rings on a zone plate
go as R squared, whereas--
sorry, the width of them,
the spacing goes as 1 over R
squared, whereas this one,
the rings are linearly spaced.
And in this case, because the
grating is linearly spaced,
all these rays go
at the same angle,
and you get the
same effect as this.
So that's how you
make Bessel beams.
So I've been interested in
them for a very long time.
And this is from another paper
of mine going back to 1978,
very long time ago.
And this here was one of
the lines of that paper,
as it says.
"A wave with zero-order Bessel
function radial distribution
propagates without change."
And so what this
is showing is what
happens if you,
instead of thinking
of the paraxial theory, what
happens to this Bessel beam
if it's not a paraxial
case, if you put, say,
this annular mask in front
of a high numerical aperture
objective lens.
And this is what you get.
So this is for
different angles--
30, 60, 90, as before.
I've even gone further here.
I've gone to 120.
And you might wonder what
that could possibly mean,
except it means you can
see that you could do it
by using a mirror, the parabolic
mirror that George spoke
about spoke about earlier.
So you can have light
coming in this way,
say, a narrow annular
beam coming in here,
so this might correspond,
say, to this case.
And then the 120 case would
be when the light's coming in
like this.
So you can actually get
a bigger than 90 degrees
by using a mirror
sort of structure.
But anyway, what you
see is what happens,
if the angle of the
focusing is small,
then it's pretty similar
to what I showed earlier
for the full lens,
full aperture.
But as you make this
angle bigger and bigger,
eventually very nasty
things start happening.
This thing starts splitting
into two spots rather than one,
and you can see that it
does more and more of that
as you make it even bigger.
And so this is all
assuming that we're
putting plane polarized
light into the lens.
So the conclusion we come so
is that putting plane polarized
light into that
lens is not really
a good idea, not good news.
And so this is explaining
things a bit more.
First of all, we look
at the black curves.
So these correspond, then-- so
a normal Airy disk is this one,
and this other one
here corresponds
to the narrow annulus.
So you can see this
is the Bessel beam.
You can see it
sharpened up quite
considerably but with some
rather larger side lobes.
But then if you go
to the high NA case--
so this is calculating it for
a numerical aperture of 1.4,
so for an [INAUDIBLE]
immersion objective.
And you'll find that
for the annulus now,
it's actually no narrower
than for the full lens.
So the polarization effects
are really basically getting
rid of any advantage in
this sharpening of the spot
that we get in this case.
But it turns out there is a
way of getting round that,
and that is to not use plane
polarized light going in.
And what we use
instead is putting
radially polarized light.
If we put in radially
polarized light--
this corresponds to
this magenta color,
so as it says here, radial.
I've also called it here
TM0 because it corresponds
to a transverse magnetic mode.
I'll show you how that
comes about in a minute.
And now you can
see for that case
we're back again to
getting something
very close to what you would
get for the paraxial case.
So there's been a
number of papers
which have exploited using
radially polarized input
into your lens in order to
get a smaller focal spot.
So yeah, this is
how it comes about,
why it's called
transverse magnetic.
So this is radially
polarized light.
Sorry, yeah, the red
is the electric field.
So that's in the
radial direction.
If we had a small
NA, it would just
be still radially polarized.
But you can see that if you
look on the complete sphere,
it starts becoming like
lines of longitude--
latitude on the sphere.
And you see the magnetic
field are these lines, which
are purely transverse,
so that's why
we call it transverse magnetic.
And the 0 corresponds to the
fact it's the lowest order
mode that's like that.
There is another case which
is azimuthal polarization.
This is where the
electric field goes
like this and the magnetic
field is like this.
So this corresponds
to TE, but I'm not
going to say anything more
about that because that doesn't
produce anything useful.
And this is-- actually, I
said there were three ways
of making these Bessel beams.
There's actually a fourth way,
which some people together
with me at the Data Storage
Institute here in Singapore
have been working
on, and this is
to use a lens with some sort
of binary optic structure.
And actually, this
was from a paper
where we were
simulating what happens
if you put radially polarized
light into this sort of system
and you optimize this
binary mask in order
to get close to a Bessel beam.
And these are the sort
of results you get.
This is along the axis you
can see that you get something
which really propagates
without spreading over
quite a long distance.
This is showing how there are
various ways of specifying how
the performance of
a focusing system.
And one way is to calculate
or measure the electric field
at the focal point for a given
amount of power going in.
And what you want, of course,
is for the power of the focus
to be--
the electric field at the
focus to be as big as possible.
And so this ratio is
this thing called F here.
And what this is showing is
that this one here is actually
for our plane polarized light
going in and showing what
happens to this
ratio as you increase
the aperture of the lens.
And so you can see
that as you increase
the aperture of the
lens, so, of course,
it focuses better and better.
And therefore for the
same amount of power
get getting going in, you get
a higher field at the focus.
So that's why it
rises like this.
But it, you see, only
gets to eventually--
the maximum it ever
gets to is a half.
And the reason it gets
to a half is because--
I showed that this
polarization is actually
equivalent to an electric
dipole plus a magnetic dipole.
And so only half of the power is
going into the electric dipole,
and it's the electric dipole
that gives an electric field
at the center.
The magnetic dipole
gives a magnetic field
at the center,
which we don't want.
So only half of the power is
going into the right thing.
So that's why that does that.
And then you can see there
another two curves here.
This one is our radially
polarized light.
So you can see that it's very
slow to get started here,
and that's because with the
radial polarized distribution,
you've got very little
power near the axis anyway.
So it eventually
starts taking off,
and you see that
at some angle here,
which is really quite big--
so this is 90 degrees
down here somewhere,
so this is going to be maybe
80 degrees or something
like that--
it overtakes the plane polarized
one and becomes better.
But you can see
there's another one,
another curve here,
which is for just
an electric dipole
on its own, so
a transverse electric dipole.
So rather than try
and give this field,
we just might try to
get this polarization.
And if we do that, then
we see we do even better.
So in this region here, you
can see this is doing better
than either of these other two.
So this is what we call
an electric dipole wave.
And this is what this
looks like, then.
This mixed dipole,
which is the electric
plus a magnetic dipole, is
equal to an electric dipole
plus a magnetic dipole.
So this is the
electric dipole field.
So what we need to
do is to make it
so that after we
focus the light,
the electric field
of the focused light
is on the surface along these
lines, like this, basically.
You see that if you look in
the region near the axis,
all these behave the same.
They're all we're all going
to be virtually linearly
polarized.
It's only when you
get so big apertures
that these become different.
And so this is now looking at
what happens with Bessel beams.
So this the so-called
mixed dipole,
which is the plain
polarization case,
for 30 degrees, 60 degrees,
90 degrees 150 degrees.
This is for the electric dipole
case, 30 degrees, 60 degrees.
Now, you see here this is
a bit better than this one.
And this one, this spot
is divided into two,
but this one hasn't
divided into two.
But it has got these
rather large side
lobes developed here.
And then if you look at this
other curve, these other ones
here, this is what I call a T1.
So this is another mode I
haven't mentioned before.
It's another TE mode, but it's
the TE1 rather than the TE0.
And you can see
this one-- actually,
ti's the same in
all these diagrams.
It's independent
of the angle now.
So you can see, actually,
this one turns out
to be slightly smaller
than this one even.
And this shows what
the TE1 looks like.
This is TE1.
So again, the electric
field is transverse.
But it's not going all
the way around like TE0.
It's going this way on this
side and this way on this side.
So if you could make
this polarization,
this would produce that results
I've just described there.
So this shows all
these different types.
So what do you have to put
into the lens to get that?
So this is what you have
to put into the lens.
So if you put it in
plane polarized light,
you get this what I call
the mixed dipole case.
In order to get electric
dipole polarization out,
you have to put in light
that looks like this.
For the magnetic dipole,
it has to look like this.
See, here it's going--
it's pointing in, and
here it's pointing out.
And for the TE1,
it's like azimuthal.
And for the TM1, it's
radial, like this.
So by altering the
polarization of the light that
goes into the lens,
you can generate all
these different mode patterns.
And this is what it does.
This is calculating the
area of the focal spot
as a function of angle for
all of these different cases.
So here there's a
whole range of them
for a full lens, full
circular aperture.
And this is for a few different
cases for the Bessel beam.
And you can see what happens is
we want this area, of course,
to be as small as possible.
And you can see that
actually in this region
here, the electric dipole
one is the smallest,
and then the TE1
is the smallest,
and then eventually the radial
one becomes the smallest.
But this doesn't
become bigger until you
get over a numerical
aperture of 0.89.
And then this is for
the full circular case.
I've got lots of
different cases here.
This one corresponds
to a paraboloid mirror.
to basically
a different apertization of
the light, which you can see it
actually is doing better
here than the others,
but eventually runs out of steam
when you get to big angles.
And you can see here, the
TE case is the smallest,
and then eventually
the radial case
is the smallest after you get
above a numerical aperture
0.91.
Now, the other thing
you'll notice, though,
about all those
spots I was showing
is they're all not symmetrical.
So what can we do to
make them symmetrical?
Well, this fits in a bit with
what we were talking about
before, the polarization case,
the circularly polarized.
The TE and the TM0 are
already circularly symmetric,
rotationally symmetric.
This one corresponds to our
normal radial polarization.
But these are the
ones, we know that x
polarized plus iy polarized
equals circular polarized.
So we can do similar
sorts of things
with these TEs or the
electric dipole polarizations.
We can add we can add one
of them along the x with one
of them along the
y with an i there,
and that actually is now
going to give something which
is rotationally symmetric.
And it actually, if you
think a lot more about it,
it corresponds to
azimuthal polarization
with a phase singularity,
with a vortex, a phase
vortex superimposed on it.
And this one corresponds to
some elliptical polarization
with a phase singularity.
So what I mean by this?
This one, azimuthal polarization
with a phase singularity,
what I mean by that is
at anywhere around here,
it's polarized in the
azimuthal direction.
But as you go round
here, the phase
changes from 0 right
around to 2 pi.
[INAUDIBLE]?
No?
OK.
So it changes.
As you go round here, it
changes from 0 to 2 pi.
So where it gets back to
here, it matches up again.
But here it's actually
changed by pi,
so it's effectively in
the opposite direction.
So that's what I mean by that.
There's a continuous
phase variation
as you go round there.
And on this one,
elliptical polarization
with a phase singularity, what
it means is that the light is--
anywhere on here, it's
elliptically polarized,
like this, say, but
at any angle it will
be a similar sort of ellipse.
But the phase of
this ellipse will
change with a face singularity
as you go around in the circle.
And so what happens
if you do that?
Well, this is what you get.
So this is looking
at the cross section
for three different angles
for all these different types.
And so this is for
Bessel beams again.
They're the simplest
to calculate.
So what we find is
that for small angles,
the radial polarized is no good.
It turns out that the reason
why radial polarization works,
actually, is because--
sorry.
I should have said this earlier.
I don't know why
I didn't, really.
Why it works is because the
light that comes down here
has got some polarization
in this direction here,
which means it's got a component
in this longitudinal direction.
So actually, the
radially polarized light
put into the lens produces a
longitudinal electric field
in the focal region.
And that might seem very
strange to people, first of all.
You can actually
generate a wave that's
moving along which has got a
longitudinal electric field.
But that seems to
be what is true.
But the point is, of course,
if this angle is small,
then this longitudinal component
is going to be very weak.
And that is why this
racially polarized one here
doesn't work well, because the
transverse field is dominating
over the longitudinal field.
But as you increase
the aperture,
you see it gets
better, like that.
And then I also show
here the electric dipole.
All these are all the same on
this, for this small angle,
but they for the larger
anguish they become different.
And this is showing how--
sorry.
This arrow has moved
itself for some reason.
I don't know why
it's moved itself,
but that this was supposed to
be pointing to this blue line
here and showing
how, in this case,
the TE1 case is the narrowest.
It's actually even narrower
than the radial in this case
here, but with some
rather slightly--
some bigger side lobes here.
And this shows also the
electric dipole case as well.
And this one's showing how the
plane polarized case is really
very bad, as we showed
earlier, once you
get to really big angles.
And then this is
comparing them a bit more.
This is actually plotting
the normalized width
of that rotationally
symmetric spot
that you get, again, for
all these different cases,
and showing--
so these are the cases
of a full aperture.
These are the cases
of a Bessel beam.
And you can see that,
actually, it turns out
that the TE annulus is the
narrowest, the TE Bessel beam,
all the time, for any angle.
It's always narrower than
the radially polarized one.
And for these cases here,
for the full circular case,
the TE one is always
narrower than the green one
until you get to
this point here,
which corresponds to a numerical
aperture of 0.98, which
is higher than you would ever
get to in a practical system.
So what this is all
showing is that, as I say,
putting plane polarized
light in is not the optimum.
It turns out that very often
the optimum can be different
according to the
circumstances, but it
can be this electric
dipole polarization
or it can be the
radially polarized input
transverse electric.
And I think I--
yeah, this is showing the
strength of the side lobes
and showing how the transverse
electric might be narrower,
but it might have
bigger side lobes.
So here the radially polarized
has smaller side lobes,
weaker side lobes, than the TE.
So and there's our
conclusions about this, then.
So if you focus plane
polarized light,
you'll get a big focal spot.
So you can improve that by
using radially polarized light,
and that comes
about because you've
got this strong longitudinal
field on the axis.
But we find that electric
dipole polarization actually
gives a higher electric
energy density at the focus,
as I showed earlier,
higher than you get
with radial polarized light.
And then I showed that the
TE1 mode polarization gives
the smallest central
lobe, and it's smaller
even than you get with
radially polarized light.
But the TE on its
own is asymmetric,
but you can make a
symmetric version of it,
which is equivalent so
azimuthal polarization
with a phase singularity.
So that's about it for what I
was going to say about this.
So this is finishing
up the course
with something which is really
sort of ongoing research
and something that,
I think, there's
a lot of people around
the world working
on these different problems
and trying to optimize
these systems to get the best
possible focusing properties
that you can get
with a high NA lens.
And I mentioned before all the
many different applications
that there's this
could be used for.
So I'm going to stop, then.
Questions?
Any questions about this?
Any questions about earlier?
There's lots of questions
about this are there?
Yeah, maybe.
There's a lot of
information there, I know.
I think you're probably all
suffering from overload.
But it's all very complicated,
actually, but very beautiful
as well, I think.
It's nice physics, I think.